the notion of the characters that had
previously been under a Fox agreement
coming back is great
number one it's nice when a company that
that that created all these characters
can have access to all those characters
it's unusual not to marvel has been in a
unique position to not have access to
the characters a long time and for me
going full circle to our conversation
that's where I started that's where I
started you know almost 20 years ago now
hey everybody is Charlie you may
remember a little while ago Kevin Feige
talking about bringing Namor into the
MCU he said that they definitely have
plans they're just trying to get the
details right when if how it's going to
happen because of all the x-men and
Fantastic Four stuff that'll be
happening really soon one of the reasons
why they were holding off on introducing
the character is is because of the
Aquaman movie they were waiting to see
it's you billion dollar franchises you
don't take too many chances if you don't
have to pretty smart move on their part
just wait and see like if audiences buy
into the idea of an underwater character
in tonally just to see what DC came up
with so now that we've all seen it in
Aquaman's on track to earn about a
billion dollars worldwide there are some
other new challenges that Marvel faces
because now that we have an underwater
character in name Wars backstory reads
so similarly to Aquaman it presents a
really interesting challenge for marble
so let's break it down there's a new
writer that I max take a giveaway to all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment about
Namor on the video so first things first
Aquaman movie nobody could have
predicted how well it would have done
like sometimes you just don't know to
you know but regardless of how you feel
about the weird pop songs and the
pitbull that they put into it people
have been voting with their dollars so
it's not so much a question of audiences
buying into the idea of an underwater
character or Atlantis because Namor is
also from Atlantis Atlantis is a
fictional place but it's taken from real
world mythology so there's no copyright
on it it's the same thing with deities
like the Greek gods like there could be
a post sidon in the Aquaman movie but
there can also be a Poseidon in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but the
biggest problem that Marvel faces is
just in the fact that Namor feels so
similar on paper to Aquaman their
backstories read very similarly they
both been retconned a couple times in
the comics if you go back to the Golden
Age they're almost the exact same
character by the
you get to the silver age there are some
differences and then in more recent
Marvel comics they have taken the
character in a dramatically different
direction than DC has taken their
Aquaman comic-book character so it's not
as bad nowadays but think about it this
way son of a sea captain in an Atlantean
Princess becomes king of Atlantis Who am
I talking about Namor or Aquaman to
answer the question I'm talking about
named war but if you're a casual
audience goer you don't read comics you
wouldn't know the difference like it
would almost be the exact same thing
Aquaman set box office records Oh an
Aquaman my goodness
but you friggin break that's right I
said something oh I remember you your
Prince Nemo right how dare you
Nemo is a clownfish do I look like a
clown fish Jimmy no I am Prince Namor
aka the Submariner
[Music]
no no Prince Namor is a somewhat obscure
Marvel character you can scale a little
bit he was here a few months ago it was
you were very upset you weren't in the
Avengers movie right yeah that's the
short version yeah so there are a couple
really easy things Marvel can do to
control public perception of its own
Atlantean king I just broke this down
like a top-five list so starting with
five Marvel introduces the character the
way they did during the Silver Age
comics the character was not originally
a Marvel comic book character Marvel
just bought the rights from the original
creators and publishers so like I said
during the Golden Age when Namor first
debuted he was almost exactly the same
as Aquaman but by the time you get to
the Silver Age Marvel gains the
characters and starts to take him in a
very different direction he becomes more
of an antihero working with people like
dr. doom so in his Silver Age
reintroduction Johnny storm of the
Fantastic Four finds Namor in a homeless
shelter with no memory of his past no
idea that he has special powers Johnny
Storm instantly recognizes who he is and
knows what he has to do in order to help
him he splashes him with salt water
knowing that it's going to help
reactivate his powers Namor gets his
memories back and goes back to Atlantis
this era of the comics is when Marvel
started saying that name war was king of
Atlantis previously he was just the son
of a sea captain in an aquatic princess
they didn't get into the game of Thrones
aspect till they started talking about
Atlantis but in the MCU just recently we
had the snap half of all life was erased
by Thanos in an instant the Avengers
will be bringing most of those people
back during Avengers end game through a
lot of different means changing the
universe on a fundamental level the
physical trauma alone from all those big
changes in such a short amount of time
is an easy way to explain how a powerful
character like Namor could have his
memory wiped and just turn up in some
unlikely place for a Fantastic Four
character in x-men or an older MCU
avenger character to find like wait a
minute you're actually like a really
powerful special person what are you
doing here how come you don't remember
where you're from but like I said
because Aquaman's so big right now if
they just come right out and say hey
we're doing a name or movie in a couple
years they will be accused of copying so
that's why they had to kind of wait a
little bit for Aquaman's stuff to cool
down before another easy way to
distinguish him is by introducing him in
someone else's giant franchise film like
say the Black Panther sequel or black
panther post-credits scene so remember
the way they introduced the black
panther character in Captain America
Civil War you don't have to give him
like a really huge backstory you don't
have to get into all the Atlantis stuff
right away Black Panther was a pretty
big character during Captain America
Civil War and when you first meet him
you just get like a really quick scene
with his father so you learn a little
bit about his relationship you learn a
little bit about who he is what his
political status is he's a prince who
then becomes king when his father dies
who wants to avenge him you don't learn
about any of the complexities of Wakanda
you don't get to see it until we get to
the Black Panther movie a couple years
later we just saw Atlantis in the
Aquaman movie obviously if Marvel ever
does a version of Atlantis it's gonna
have to look radically different the
easiest way to avoid that landmine is
just step around it and not do Atlantis
for a long time we've already gotten
that Atlantis Easter egg scene at the
end of Iron Man 2 when Nick Fury is
grilling Iron Man about the Avengers
initiative
I don't think I want you looking at that
I'm not sure pertains to you anymore so
in that scene you actually look in the
background on that map right next to
Wakanda is Atlantis right here in the
middle of the Atlantic Ocean that's one
of those Odin's vault style Marvel phase
one Easter eggs like hey look in the
background if you're a big comic book
fan you'll probably recognize that that
is Atlantis maybe we'll do that someday
and even though they've done it in some
funny ways they've paid off all those
Odin's vault Easter eggs like the
gauntlet turned out to be fake but in
time they explained what all those
things were so eventually we got our
Black Panther movie because it's on the
map in the background here next to
Atlantis that just means that eventually
we'll get a version of Atlantis as well
in some way three you introduced Namor
as a villain like I said in the Silver
Age when they reintroduce the character
he was spending more time with dr. doom
Aquaman is like this big goofy surfer
bro hero and I mean even on comic book
page they read as very different
characters even though comic book
Aquaman is very different from Jason
Momoa movie Aquaman but just because you
introduced Namor as a villain doesn't
mean that he has to be completely
joyless or humorless Black Panther is a
really good example of a hero that
doesn't spend a lot of time telling
jokes but is not humorless you put a lot
of people around him like Cherie they
bring a lot of the comedy into those
scenes and he reacts off of them once
you spend a couple movies developing his
character you can do the Loki thing
where he becomes more of an antihero
later in his run regardless of whether
or not he continues to align himself
with the villains of the MCU in two you
know you stay totally consistent with
the comic book version of the character
in his initial appearances in other
people's movies this is where we get to
the pitbull at all because a lot of
people when they're trying to criticize
Marvel films say that the tone is too
light black panther is a really good
example of a Marvel film that does have
a lot of humor but totally you know
amongst all the other Marvel characters
just feels like a more serious film than
say like the Iron Man films because
unlike Iron Man you don't have black
panther equiping at every turn joking
about every single situation no matter
how bad things get which is kind of what
you have going on with the Aquaman movie
it's a lot harder to say movies are
similar when they just
feel totally incredibly different in
number one probably the best thing that
Marvel could do with an antihero or
villainous bent character like name or
to differentiate him would be to make
him part of a larger play towards an MCU
version of something like the Cabal
you know big crossover team between
Fantastic Four x-men and traditional MCU
characters is a sort of anti Avengers
group because we don't have the
Illuminati and technically the Cabal is
like the evil version of the Illuminati
smaller version of that would be like
the sinister six inside a spider-man
film like a group of really good villain
characters that you spend several movies
developing so that when they all come
together
Avengers style or anti Avenger style you
actually care about all of them really
good example of this is when Marvel
spends several films getting you to care
about the relationship between Captain
America and Iron Man in the relationship
between Captain America and Bucky so
that when they did the big twist in
civil war iron man learning the Bucky
killed his parents
you totally buy into it and genuinely
care about everyone in that fight all
three of them so early prediction right
now Marvel still waits a couple years
before even thinking about introducing
the name or a character but I definitely
think they do him eventually just
because audiences have already bought
into the concept of an aquatic base
character like that in right now anyway
the big-ticket item on Kevin Feige mind
is unfolding in the Fox x-men characters
Namor sort of a bonus addition to that
kind of stuff and we will be talking a
lot about x-men plans inside the MCU I
already posted that video of Kevin Feige
talking about his x-men plans this year
click here to watch that and click here
to learn why Marvel just retcon Thor and
Loki ahead of Avengers endgame thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]